Rome, mercredi 13 mai 1981.
Il est 17h.
La place Saint-Pierre est noire de monde.
Comme chaque mercredi, le pape,
va donner une audience publique
à la foule des pèlerins.
Les fidèles ont les yeux rivés
sur sa silhouette blanche.
L'heure est à la bousculade
et à la joie populaire.
Mais dans la foule, un homme
s'apprête à commettre l'irréparable.
Soudain, trois coups de feu.
J'ai tout de suite compris que quelque chose
de terrible venait d'arriver.
Jean-paul II s'est effondré.
On a tiré sur le pape.
Les gens gesticulaient,
les gens pleuraient,
Les gens criaient.
La nouvelle, à peine croyable,
sidère les témoins.
Bientôt, elle va foudroyer
les agences de presse et les rédactions.
Cet après-midi à 17h20, un attentat
a été commis à Rome contre la personne,
du pape Jean-Paul II.
Elle sera reprise et diffusée
partout, jusqu'au bout du monde,
pendant des heures.
On a tiré sur le pape, on a tenté
d'assassiner Jean-Paul II.
Le pape est touché à l'abdomen. On le
transporte jusqu'à la clinique Gemelli,
a six kilomètres de là.
Son ambulance doit se frayer un chemin
dans la circulation romaine,
qui est très dense
en cette fin d'après-midi.
Le pape est entouré
de son secrétaire et d'un médecin.
Il va bientôt perdre connaissance et il
sera admis dans un état plus que critique.
On va devoir l'opérer à chaud.
A 20h, un premier communiqué officiel
est lu place Saint-Pierre.
Il se veut plutôt rassurant.
La nouvelle de cet attentat
n'en est pas moins fracassante.
Aussi impensable que cela paraisse
en ce 13 mai 1981, en plein Vatican,
on a attenté à la vie du pape.
Ça ne s'était jamais vu !
Alors, qui a tiré ?
Pourquoi ?
À l'issue de quel terrible engrenage ?
Ce que je vous propose,
c'est de revivre ce moment d'histoire,
et de reconstituer les circonstances
qui devaient aboutir au drame.
Pour cela,
revenons quelques années en arrière.
16 octobre 1978,
même endroit, la place Saint-Pierre.
Même genre de foule,
deux ans et demi plus tôt.
Les observateurs scrutent
sur les toits du palais pontifical,
la modeste et néanmoins célèbre
cheminée de la chapelle Sixtine.
Tous, attendent l'émission
d'une fumée blanche,
signal de l'élection d'un nouveau pape.
Celui qu'il faut remplacer a régné
sous le nom de Jean-Paul 1ᵉʳ.
Bien peu de temps d'ailleurs,
33 jours, pas un de plus.
Les cardinaux vont-ils, pour une fois,
renoncer à élire un pape italien,
et choisir le successeur de Saint-Pierre parmi
leurs confrères d'Afrique ou d'Amérique latine ?
Certains s'interrogent,
mais cela paraît tout de même improbable.
Parmi les spécialistes, l'attente est grande
et les pronostics vont bon train.
Durant le conclave, après Jean-Paul Iᵉʳ,
nous savions que Wojtyla
avait les capacités pour devenir pape.
Mais nous n'avions jamais envisagé
qu'il puisse être élu,
car la puissance de la curie romaine
était telle,
que personne ne s'attendait
à un pape étranger,
qui plus est un pape de l'est.
Ce 16 octobre 1978 à 18h18, la fumée
blanche annonce que les cardinaux,
se sont mis d'accord sur un nom.
Bientôt, des projecteurs illuminent
la façade de la basilique Saint-Pierre.
Au grand balcon apparaît le cardinal Felici
qui, ému comme il se doit,
prononce les mots  rituels.
Nous avons un pape.
Le monde entier retient son souffle et c'est
une stupéfaction intense,
qui accueille le nom du nouvel élu.
Son éminentissime et révérendissime,
Karol, Charles,
Cardinal Wojtyla.
La surprise a été forte, même pour nous,
quand le cardinal Felici a prononcé
le nom du cardinal Wojtyla.
Carrément à la Polonaise, il a dit : "Wojtyla".
En insistant sur ces formules Wojtyla,
et pour les gens et pour nous aussi,
on estimait que c'était en africain.
Mais il s'agit bien de Karol Wojtyla,
c'est à dire le cardinal archevêque
de Cracovie en  Pologne, un pape venu de l'Est.
Lorsque nous avons entendu l'annonce.
"Habemus papam Cardinal Wojtyla"
Le polonais !
C'était une énorme surprise
pour tous les Italiens.
Il a pris comme nom, vient de dire
le cardinal Pericle Felici,
le nom de Jean-Paul II.
Certes, en Pologne, un pays réputé
pour son fervent catholicisme,
le cardinal Wojtyla a fait parler
de lui depuis des années,
par son franc parler,
par sa foi communicative,
par son engagement en faveur
des droits de l'homme.
Mais de là à faire de lui un pape,
songez, le premier pape qui ne soit
pas italien depuis des siècles.
C'est une surprise.
Ce pape n'est pas un Italien.
Il s'agit de l'archevêque
de Cracovie, un Polonais,
donc le cardinal Karol Wojtyla.
La divine surprise au Vatican, ce soir avec
l'annonce de l'élection du nouveau pape,
le cardinal polonais Karol Wojtyla.
Sans attendre, les observateurs
les plus avisés,
prennent la mesure de l'incroyable
audace du Sacré Collège.
En élisant un pape polonais,
les cardinaux viennent avant tout d'adresser
un défi frontal à tout le monde communiste.
On a tout de suite imaginé que ça risquait
de créer des répercussions politiques.
Un homme du pays de l'Est et évidemment,
dans une situation
encore de guerre froide.
Ça avait l'air presque d'une provocation.
N'oublions pas qu'à cette époque,
dans un climat de guerre froide,
alors que les arsenaux nucléaires
de part et d'autre sont gigantesques,
la Pologne est un des points faibles
de ce qu'on appelle le bloc de l'Est,
Cet empire impénétrable édifié par Staline
autour de l'Union soviétique.
C'est en 1958 que Karol Wojtyla
est devenu le plus jeune évêque polonais.
Il n'a alors plus cessé de pousser à la
résistance au matérialisme communiste,
et à la création de mouvements
chrétiens clandestins.
Un combat qui va peser lourd
sur les événements à venir.
Nous connaissions Wojtyla
pour son œuvre à Cracovie.
Je l'avais rencontré quand il était évêque
alors qu'il combattait déjà le communisme.
Aux yeux de Moscou,
du Kremlin, de Brejnev.
Wojtyla est un homme dangereux.
Et c'est cet homme qui vient d'être
investi de la formidable,
de l'incomparable autorité papale.
Très vite auprès de Jean-Paul II,
une figure nouvelle va s'imposer,
celle de son secrétaire,
évidemment polonais.
Nous avons rencontré
le cardinal Stanisław Dziwisz,
qui est aujourd'hui
archevêque de Cracovie.
Il a accompagné Jean-Paul II
depuis les années 60,
jusqu'aux derniers instants de sa vie.
Karol Wojtyla était un évêque
qui dérangeait le régime communiste.
À tel point qu'avant le conclave,
avant le départ pour Rome,
ils lui ont confisqué
son passeport diplomatique.
On ne lui a accordé qu'un passeport touristique
valable pour un seul voyage.
En plus de cela, un des dirigeants
du Parti communiste a dit :
"D'accord, qu'il y aille, mais quand
il reviendra, on réglera nos comptes avec lui."
Mais il n'est pas revenu,
et pour cause, il est resté à Rome.
Nous sommes à nouveau, en ce moment,
en direct avec Rome.
Retour au 16 octobre 1978 à 19h35.
Le nouveau Souverain Pontife apparaît
enfin sur la loggia de Saint-Pierre.
Souriant, détendu,
débordant d'une énergie évidente.
A 58 ans, Karol Wojtyla devient
Sa Sainteté le Pape Jean-Paul II,
et il paraît bien plus
vigoureux que ses prédécesseurs.
Regardez le bénir la foule,
ce pape polonais,
écoutez ses premiers mots
en tant que pontife.
Et voilà, que les cardinaux,
on appelait un nouvel évêque de Rome.
Sa voix est forte,
posée, rassurante.
Ils l'ont appelé,
d'un pays lointain.
Je crois pouvoir dire qu'en quelques minutes,
la planète entière est conquise.
On imagine les grimaces, les soupirs
dans les couloirs du Kremlin.
Comment un tel pape ne se mêlerait-il
pas des affaires du monde ?
La télévision, ici en Pologne,
n'a pas annoncé immédiatement
l'élection de Karol Wojtyla.
Je ne sais pas qui ils ont consultés.
Certains disent que c'était peut-être Moscou.
Et c'est avec retard qu'ils ont annoncé
l'élection d'une simple phrase.
"Le conclave a choisi comme pape
le cardinal de Cracovie, Karol Wojtyla."
Sans aucun autre commentaire.
Il est apparu au balcon, il a parlé,
il s'est excusé parce qu'il
ne parlait pas bien l'italien,
mais nous avons tout de suite
compris que cet homme allait changer,
l'histoire des pays de l'Est
et la politique dans le monde.
Le 20 octobre 1978, lors de la messe
inaugurale de son pontificat,
le pape lance au monde ce
qui va devenir un message clé.
N'ayez pas peur.
Ouvrez toutes grandes les portes du Christ,
À sa puissance salvatrice.
Ouvrez,
Ouvrez les frontières des Etats,
le système économique et politique,
ainsi que les immenses
domaines de la culture,
du développement et de la civilisation.
N'ayez pas peur !
Ces mots sont restés.
Ouvrez votre porte au Christ,
N'ayez pas peur.
C'était le programme du pontificat.
Ces mots s'adressaient en particulier
aux pays où la dictature sévissait,
que ce soit de droite ou de gauche.
Ces mots ont libéré les gens de la peur.
Parce que les dictatures règnent
par la violence et par la peur.
C'était le résumé de toute la politique
ecclésiastique de Wojtyla.
"N'ayez pas peur", signifiait exactement
n'ayez pas peur en politique.
N'ayez pas peur en religion.
N'ayez pas peur dans la vie quotidienne.
N'ayez pas peur non plus
face à vos ennemis.
Donc, "n'ayez pas peur" c'était comme
ouvrir une grande fenêtre sur le monde,
une fenêtre qui donnait sur la paix.
"N'ayez pas peur", ces mots vont peser sur
l'avenir du monde, mais nous le verrons,
ils ont peut être aussi contribué à mettre
en danger la vie du nouveau pape.
N'allons pas trop vite.
D'emblée, Jean-Paul II
va manifester l'intention,
de sortir du Vatican
le plus souvent possible,
et de multiplier les déplacements
dans le monde.
Or, tout naturellement, il réserve
un de ses premiers voyages à la Pologne.
Voyage triomphal, fondateur,
voyage historique.
À Cracovie, 1 million et demi de personnes
accueillent en sauveur,
celui qui leur propose
d'ouvrir les frontières.
C'est une ferveur inouïe qui s'empare
de toute une partie de la population polonaise.
L'agitation prend même
une ampleur incontrôlable.
Dites vous bien que dès le mois d'août 80,
les chantiers navals de Gdansk,
sur la mer Baltique, sont en grève.
On craint une répression brutale de la part
du régime et de ses soutiens soviétiques.
Des rumeurs font état d'une présence
menaçante de l'Armée rouge aux frontières.
Question : Est-ce que Moscou va une fois
de plus choisir le coup de force ?
Le monde a les yeux rivés sur la Pologne et
sur les agitateurs du syndicat Solidarnosc,
Solidarité conduit par un ouvrier
électricien du nom de Lech Walesa.
Il ne cache pas la force qui le guide,
c'est la foi en Dieu.
À Gdansk, les ouvriers en grève,
défilent derrière des bannières
de la Vierge noire de Częstochowa.
Les reportages les montrent
s'agenouillant pour prier,
et chanter des cantiques
devant des autels de fortune.
Et sous l'enseigne géante
des chantiers Lénine,
Le monde étonné, inquiet,
voit apparaître
le portrait du nouveau pape.
Un pape qui d'emblée
devient un pape politique.
La Pologne, mais pas seulement la Pologne,
mais également les autres pays,
qui étaient sous le joug
du régime communiste,
ont compris que quelque chose allait changer.
Ils ont vu un espoir avec ce nouveau pape,
ce nouveau pontificat.
Alors entendons nous bien, à cette époque,
le soutien de Rome aux ouvriers polonais
reste discret,
et l'action de l'Église demeure
largement souterraine.
Il n'empêche, le mouvement syndical polonais
obtient gain de cause.
31 août 1980, Lech Walesa
signe les accords de Gdansk.
Lech Walesa, devenu le héros de la lutte
contre un empire communiste désavoué,
par sa base ouvrière et qui ne tardera
pas à être reçu solennellement,
sous les ors du Vatican.
Pour Moscou, ces provocations
sont choquantes, inacceptables.
En quelques mois, le cardinal Wojtyla,
devenu le pape Jean-Paul II,
apparaît comme le symbole d'une résistance
tranquille au totalitarisme.
Car c'est bien d'une résistance tranquille,
presque bonhomme encore, que nous parlons.
Mais bientôt, pour certains,
Jean-Paul II devient,
l'homme à abattre.
Le pape libérait la Pologne et toutes
ses nations opprimées par la force de la parole.
La force de conviction.
Il n'avait pas d'armes. La force
de la parole, de la persuasion,
ont donné de la force à ces nations.
Les gens ont compris qu'il était
possible de vivre différemment,
qu'on pouvait vivre,
travailler et être libres.
Le puissant message de Jean-Paul II
n'est pas entendu seulement,
par les masses prisonnières
du vieux rideau de fer.
partout dans le monde.
En Amérique du Sud notamment,
mais aussi en Afrique,
les peuples sans enthousiasme pour ce pape
à la parole forte, libératrice.
Au fil des mois,
cela s'impose comme une évidence.
Jean-paul II entend faire de ses nombreux
voyages un formidable outil politique.
Pas seulement dans le bloc de l'Est.
Décembre 1979,
Jean-Paul II se rend en Turquie.
Un déplacement sous haute surveillance.
Car sur le pape, une menace plane.
En effet, à l'époque, la Turquie joue le rôle
de base avancée des Etats-Unis,
face aux pays de l'Est,
mais aussi face à l'Iran.
L'Iran, où une révolution islamique est en
train de renverser le régime autoritaire du Shah.
Autant dire qu'Istanbul et Ankara,
sont devenus des nids d'espions,
où se croisent agents
du KGB et de la CIA.
Pour la visite du pape, les autorités
ont mis le pays en état de siège.
Elles ont annulé les bains de foule,
et forcé le souverain pontife
à revêtir un gilet pare-balles.
La raison de ces mesures alors inédites,
des menaces directes proférées
contre Jean-Paul II,
par un terroriste du nom d'Ali Ağca.
Ali Ağca fait partie des Loups Gris,
une organisation terroriste
d'extrême droite,
qui depuis des années met la Turquie
à feu et à sang.
Ces Loups Gris sont liés à la mafia,
ainsi qu'aux différents
services de renseignement,
aussi bien américains que soviétiques.
Leurs activités sont financées par d'intenses
trafics d'armes et de drogue,
au Moyen-Orient et en Europe.
Au sein de cette organisation,
Ali Ağca n'est pas un simple petit rouage.
Son rôle est celui d'un tueur.
Au printemps 79, quelques mois
à peine avant la visite du pape,
Ağca, qui a tout juste 21 ans,
a été arrêté pour l'assassinat du
rédacteur en chef de Milliyet,
un des principaux quotidiens turcs.
Après onze jours d'interrogatoire, il a été
poussé devant les caméras de la télévision.
"C'est moi seul qu'il l'ait tué",
a-t-il déclaré.
"C'est un acte politique.
C'est moi seul qui ait pris cette décision."
La photo du tueur autoproclamé
fait la une des journaux.
Et si la plupart des analystes
ont considéré Agca comme un fou,
lui n'a plus cessé de se considérer
comme l'empereur,
autant dire le caïd des loups gris.
Or, le 25 novembre 79, quelques semaines
seulement avant la visite du pape,
Ali Agca s'est évadé de sa prison militaire.
Il l'a fait grâce à
des agents des Loups gris,
infiltrés dans le service de sécurité.
Il a aussitôt appelé le journal Milliyet
et a lancé au téléphone :
"C'est l'empereur, je me suis évadé.
Vous allez recevoir une lettre."
Cette lettre, voici sa teneur.
Les impérialistes occidentaux envoient en
Turquie le commandant des croisés Jean-Paul,
déguisé en chef religieux.
Si cette visite n'est pas annulée,
je tuerais à coup sûr le pape.
C'est l'unique motif de mon évasion."
On nous avait dit qu'il avait
tué un journaliste.
Qu'il s'était évadé de prison.
Donc nous avions peur
qu'il se passe quelque chose.
C'est pour ça que lors
de ce voyage en Turquie,
nous avons pris toutes les mesures
de sécurité possibles.
Cette fois-ci, les menaces d'Ali Agca
resteront sans effet.
Il ne passe pas à l'acte.
Grâce à un complice du nom d'Oral Celik,
il a fui la Turquie muni d'un faux passeport,
et s'est caché pour un temps dans
l'Iran de la Révolution islamique,
l'Iran de l'ayatollah Khomeiny.
Puis il est passé clandestinement
en Bulgarie.
On le verra en Allemagne,
en Suisse, en Italie,
et même en Tunisie
à l'heure des vacances.
Et notez bien ceci,
c'est lors de son séjour à Sofia,
en Bulgarie,
qu'un parrain de la mafia turc lui aurait
proposé 3 millions de Deutsche Mark,
pour assassiner le pape.
Il faut croire que le contrat
a bien été passé,
car au printemps 1981, le jeune agent
des Loups Gris arrive à Rome,
sous un faux nom et se promène,
au milieu de la foule des touristes
qui visitent le Vatican.
12 mai 1981.
En début d'après-midi, Ali Agca, quitte
son petit hôtel de la Via Cicerone,
non loin du Tibre.
La pensione Isa.
Nous sommes dans un quartier historique,
touristique et très agréable.
À quelques centaines de mètres seulement
de la place Saint-Pierre.
Agca se rend d'abord à la consigne
automatique de la gare Termini,
où il dépose dans trois casiers différents,
trois petites valises contenant
des vêtements de rechange,
et plusieurs faux passeports.
Il retrouve ensuite son complice
de toujours Oral Celik,
celui là même qui l'avait
fait sortir de Turquie.
Les deux jeunes hommes possèdent des armes
achetées à Vienne par Agca,
le 12 mai.
Ils ont prévu d'agir dès le lendemain en
profitant du bain de foule du pape,
à l'issue de sa traditionnelle audience
publique du mercredi.
Vous avez bien entendu, il ne leur reste que
quelques heures pour tout mettre en place.
Leur plan est tout simple.
L'un et l'autre ont l'intention
de tirer sur le souverain pontife.
Ali Agca depuis la barrière en bordure
du passage de la jeep papale.
Autant dire à bout portant.
Oral Celik, son complice, depuis un
poste situé 20 mètres en arrière.
Il est prévu que dans la foulée,
Celik fasse exploser une grenade
afin de faire diversion,
et de faciliter leur fuite à tous deux.
Reste à régler deux ou trois détails.
Ils font notamment
l'acquisition d'une sacoche,
destinée à cacher la grenade
que Celik doit transporter.
Puis les deux complices se mettent
à la recherche d'un endroit sûr,
où garer la voiture
qui leur permettra de fuir.
Ils jettent leur dévolu
sur un emplacement dégagé,
à proximité de l'ambassade du Canada.
Après quoi,
revenu sur la place Saint-Pierre,
à l'ombre des grandes colonnes du Bernin,
Ali Agca et Oral Celik
se mêlent aux touristes.
Ils sont les deux seuls, à savoir
que Jean-Paul II, selon toute vraisemblance,
a désormais moins de 24h à vivre.
Un compte à rebours s'est enclenché,
dont Jean-Paul II lui-même
est loin de se douter.
Le Saint-Père, après une après-midi
de travail à son bureau,
s'accorde en ce moment même une petite
marche dans les jardins du Vatican.
Il se rend au centre médical,
où le directeur,
le docteur Renato Buzzonetti,
lui présente la nouvelle ambulance
qui vient d'arriver.
Nous avons rencontré le docteur Buzzonetti,
médecin personnel du pape, et qui restera
jusqu'à la fin aux côtés de Jean-Paul II.
Devant la porte de l'infirmerie,
il y avait notre ambulance,
équipée d'un central de réanimation.
Et le pape a béni l'ambulance.
Il a béni les médecins de garde,
et puis il a dit au revoir.
À très vite.
Le pape asperge le véhicule
d'eau bénite et déclare :
"Je bénis aussi le premier patient
qui sera transporté dans ce véhicule."
Comment pourrait-il imaginer que ce
malheureux ne sera personne d'autre que lui ?
De retour à ses appartements,
le souverain pontife va dîner tôt
en compagnie de ses  secrétaires.
Puis il regarde d'un œil le
journal télévisé de la RAI.
En Irlande, les émeutes consécutives
à la mort de Bobby Sands,
mort en prison d'une grève de la faim,
sont en train de se résorber.
En France, pour la première fois
sous la cinquième République,
on vient d'élire un président socialiste.
On parle aussi de la Pologne
et des tensions qui s'y avivent.
Le pape a soudain paru plus attentif.
Il regagne son bureau privé.
Au même moment, Via Cicerone,
Ali Agca a proposé à une femme de chambre
de l'accompagner au cinéma.
Le film qu'ils ont choisi :
Jésus de Nazareth, de Franco  Zeffirelli.
Ils prennent ensuite un verre
à la terrasse d'un café, puis rentrent,
à la pension et se couchent ensemble,
près de la table de nuit où Ali Agca
a déposé son browning chargé.
Quand la jeune femme lui demande
ce qu'il est venu faire à Rome,
il répond qu'il a l'intention
d'y accomplir une grande œuvre.
A 23h30, au second étage
du palais pontifical,
les lumières se sont éteintes.
Le matin du 13 mai, Ali Agca
s'est levé de bonne heure.
Il a commencé par quelques exercices,
suivis d'une douche glacée.
Puis, après la première
prière de la journée,
il a revêtu la plus sobre des tenues :
Chemise blanche, veston gris,
chaussures noires.
Rien de voyant.
Sur un bout de papier,
il a tracé les mots suivants en turc.
"J'ai tiré sur le pape pour que le monde
se souvienne des milliers de victimes,
de l'impérialisme américain et soviétique
en Afghanistan et au Salvador,
et dans le Tiers-Monde."
Message pour le moins obscure
et qui devait se prêter par la suite,
à beaucoup d'interprétations.
Le loup gris glisse
la note dans sa poche,
il ouvre le tiroir de sa table de nuit,
se saisit du revolver chargé,
puis il sort de la chambre, laissant derrière
lui toutes ses affaires, même son passeport.
Pendant ce temps, au Palais pontifical,
le pape est déjà en audience.
Il reçoit ce matin
un grand généticien français,
le professeur Lejeune, connu pour ses
positions très fermes contre l'avortement.
Le scientifique et son épouse ont assisté
dès 7h30 à la messe privée du pape.
À midi, ils vont partager son déjeuner,
puis ils s'envoleront aussitôt pour Paris.
A 13h, Ali Agca et Oral Celik se sont
retrouvés pour déjeuner Piazza Barberini,
devant la fontaine du Triton.
Agca porte en bandoulière le petit
sac où il cache son browning chargé.
Celik a dissimulé son Beretta 7 65
sous un blouson de cuir.
Il porte un jeans et des baskets,
et tient la sacoche achetée la veille.
Une sacoche où se trouve
à présent la fameuse grenade.
Après déjeuner, les deux jeunes hommes s'accordent
un dernier verre dans un bar de la Via Traspontina.
Puis ils se dirigent vers
la place Saint-Pierre.
Il est alors 15h30.
En ce 13 mai 81, un vent
de sirocco balaie la ville éternelle.
Il fait chaud et sec, place Saint-Pierre,
où se prépare l'audience publique qui,
à la belle saison,
se déroule en plein air.
Depuis son avènement,
deux ans et demi plus tôt,
Jean-Paul II a fait de ces rendez-vous
populaires du mercredi,
un véritable spectacle,
où la foule applaudit et agite des foulards
blancs entre une prière et un cantique.
Il avait ce don d'aller au devant des foules,
et en même temps, lors de ses rencontres,
c'est comme s'il voyait les gens un par un.
Individuellement.
Les gens le ressentaient comme ça,
comme une rencontre individuelle
avec chaque personne présente.
Et c'était très beau.
Jusqu'à aujourd'hui, les gens,
quand ils en parlent, disent :
"Il m'a regardé,
je vois encore son regard."
Cet après-midi, près de 20 000 fidèles
sont déjà en place.
A 16h30, au bureau mobile
de la Poste du Vatican,
qui est installé sur la place même,
Agca et Celik achète des cartes postales,
histoire de passer pour des touristes.
Puis les deux hommes se mettent en place.
Asha s'installe près de la barrière de bois,
au bord de l'étroit couloir
où doit passer la jeep blanche du pape.
Celik, lui, se positionne
au milieu de la foule.
À quelques encablures, à l'ombre
de la porte des cloches,
Le pape est en train de grimper à bord.
Son secrétaire, Stanislaw Dziwisz,
est à ses côtés.
Les gens ont commencé à se rassembler.
La place était pleine.
Il y avait énormément de monde.
Le pape est aussi flanqué de son majordome,
de quelques policiers en civil,
chargés de sa garde rapprochée,
ainsi que de son photographe
attitré Arturo Mari.
Depuis le début du pontificat, Arturo Mari
suit le Saint-Père dans tous ses déplacements.
Les deux hommes sont devenus très proches.
Le photographe est revenu
pour nous sur cette journée,
gravée à tout jamais dans sa mémoire.
J'étais juste à côté du pape.
De la main gauche,
je me tenais à la jeep.
Je marchais à reculons,
et avec l'appareil photo, je cadrais
le pape avec la  foule en dessous.
Dès que la voiture apparaît, un tonnerre
d'acclamations s'élève de la foule,
que la jeep va fendre lentement
selon un trajet circulaire.
Je me tenais à l'ombre de la colonnade,
et je regardais la foule de loin
qui saluait Jean-Paul II,
qui est arrivé en Jeep blanche.
Le pape se tient d'une main à une rambarde
et de l'autre bénit l'assistance,
et touche des mains
qui se tendent vers lui.
Quand les papes sortaient
ou passaient sur la place,
ou allaient quelque part, aussi bien
les gardes suisses que les gendarmes,
pour un signe de respect,
étaient tournés vers le papes.
Les gardes suisses
se mettaient même à genoux,
devant le pape.
Il ne regardaient pas du tout la foule.
Personne n'osait imaginer que quelqu'un
aurait pu tirer sur le pape. Franchement.
Personne ne voit Al Agca si près
maintenant de la voiture.
Plus loin, à 40 mètres environ,
un homme a grimpé sur une fontaine
et prend des photos.
Cet homme, un Américain,
s'appelle Lowell Newton,
Il est journaliste pour la chaîne ABC.
La jeep, très proche,
roule en direction
de la colonnade de droite,
celle qui se termine
par la porte de bronze.
Agca plonge la main dans son petit sac,
et crispe les doigts sur son arme.
20 mètres derrière lui,
Celik serre la sienne contre lui,
dans la sacoche,
il y a la grenade offensive,
prête à être dégoupillée.
Une femme dans sa fillette vers le pape
qui la prend dans ses bras.
La petite fille Sarah Bartoli tient
entre ses doigts le cordon d'un ballon bleu.
Le pape embrasse l'enfant
et la rend à sa mère.
Des dizaines de témoins
photographient la scène.
Le pape arrive à la hauteur
de la porte de bronze,
il est alors à trois mètres du tueur.
La main droite d'Ali Agca
pointe le Browning.
Ses yeux fixent la cible.
Agca tire une première fois.
Il est 17h19.
La silhouette du pape s'affaisse.
Celik tire à son tour.
Puis Agca une deuxième fois.
J'ai tout de suite compris que quelque
chose de terrible venait d'arriver.
Je me souviens de ces pigeons qui,
au bruit des tirs, se sont envolés.
La confusion régnait sur la place.
J'ai demandé au Saint Père qui
commençait déjà à perdre ses forces.
"Qu'est-ce qu'il s'est passé ?"
"On m'a tiré dessus."
J'ai remarqué quelque chose d'étrange.
Tous les pigeons posaient sur la place
Saint-Pierre se sont envolés.
Alors j'ai compris
que quelque chose était arrivé.
Sans même avoir
entendu les détonations.
On peut s'imaginer d'abord une peur.
Mais qu'est-ce qui s'est passé ?
Je demande au Saint-Père,
est-ce que ça fait mal ?
Il me répond qu'on lui a tiré dans
le ventre et que ça lui fait mal.
Il a vite commencé à perdre ses forces.
J'ai pris en photo l'attentat.
Quand il tombe dans la Jeep.
Je dois vous dire en toute conscience,
que je ne me souviens pas
comment je les ai prises.
L'expérience.
La Madone a guidé ma main.
Je ne sais pas.
Le plus important pour moi est
que l'événement ait été documenté.
Ça a été peut-être le moment
le plus horrible de ma vie.
Car le rapport que j'avais
avec le Saint-père,
il m'a traité comme un fils.
Si bien que sur le moment,
c'est mon père qui était mort.
Dans la foule, c'est la stupeur.
Les gens gesticuler,
les gens pleurer,
les gens crier.
En peu de temps, tout le monde a compris qu'il
s'agissait d'un attentat contre le Pape.
Seulement, personne ne savait
s'ils étaient morts ou vivants.
La garde du Vatican est arrivée
pour nous faire évacuer la place.
Nous sommes partis très vite.
Il fallait sauver le pape
qui perdait ses forces.
On peut le dire, il était mourant.
Ils ont étendu le Saint-père au sol,
à l'entrée du centre médical.
Et on attendait une ambulance
car nous n'étions pas préparés.
Nous avions peu de temps.
C'est ici, sur ce carrelage,
que l'on a allongé le Saint-Père.
Là aussi, j'étais près de lui,
et je n'ai jamais entendu
un gémissement.
Seulement une phrase.
Ma Madone aide moi.
Ne m'abandonne pas.
Oui, il disait ça en Polonais.
J'ignorais ce qui s'était passé.
Je voyais le pape blessé, ensanglanté.
Je lui ai demandé comment il se sentait
et il m'a répondu.
Il était donc parfaitement conscient.
Je lui ai fait bouger les bras,
bouger les jambes.
Je lui ai pris son pouls.
Le pape a été mis dans l'ambulance,
et je suis resté à ses côtés avec
son secrétaire, Stanislaw Dziwisz.
Dans l'ambulance,
il perdait déjà connaissance.
Et en arrivant à la clinique,
il était inconscient.
Le médecin du pape est venu vers moi,
en me disant que la situation
était délicate.
Qu'on arrivait à peine
à sentir sa tension,
et les battements de son cœur.
Il a dit : "Que Monseigneur lui
donne l'extrême onction."
C'est comme ça que
l'on disait à l'époque,
le sacrement des malades.
C'était des moments tragiques.
Une radio a même annoncé
qu'il était mort.
La situation était très délicate.
L'attentat avait pour but
de tuer, absolument.
Mais Dieu a finalement fait que
l'on a réussi à maîtriser la situation.
Ce 13 mai 1981,
Jean-paul II aurait pu, aurait dû mourir.
Les circonstances ou la Providence,
ou son énergique constitution
en ont voulu autrement.
Le lundi suivant,
c'était le 18 mai,
le pape fêtait ses 61 ans.
À l'aube,
j'étais là jour et nuit,
Je lui ai apporté sur le lit une rose
rouge que ma femme m'avait donné,
pour que je la donne au pape
comme cadeau d'anniversaire.
Notez bien qu'en bon pape qu'il était,
Jean-Paul II a pardonné à son agresseur,
et même plutôt deux fois qu'une.
Quatre jours seulement après l'attentat,
il célèbre déjà une messe dominicale
en direct depuis son lit d'hôpital.
Son message est retransmis
place Saint-Pierre.
Le pape, je cite : "prie pour son frère,
celui qui lui a tiré dessus
et à qui il a complètement pardonné."
Mais revenons à ce 13 mai 81
et à l'arrestation d'Ali Agca.
Le tireur a tenté d'appuyer
une troisième fois sur la détente,
mais son geste a été arrêté
comme par miracle,
quelqu'un lui a saisi le bras.
Une religieuse, sœur Laetitia.
L'arme tombe à terre.
La sœur s'accroche désespérément à Agca,
jusqu'à ce qu'un homme le plaque au sol.
Le tireur se débat, tente à toutes forces
de s'échapper, mais il est trop tard,
des policiers arrivent,
l'entourent, l'immobilisent.
Sur la place Saint Pierre,
on a évité un carnage.
La chance a voulu que le complice d'Ali Agca,
Oral Celik ait cédé à la panique,
et renoncé à dégoupiller sa grenade.
Il va se fondre dans la foule.
Pendant ce temps, Ali Agca solidement
encadré par deux policiers en uniforme,
est conduit directement au siège
central de la police romaine.
Il sera interrogé par les inspecteurs
de la DIGOS, la police antiterroriste.
"Je suis Mehmet Ali Agca, le plus grand
terroriste turc !" Leur lance t-il.
"J'appartiens à une nouvelle race internationale.
Je suis au delà des idéologies."
L'homme est-il fou ou bien essaie
t-il de brouiller les pistes ?
L'enquête est lancée.
Nous avons rencontré Lindano Marchionne,
commissaire de la police antiterroriste.
C'est lui qui va diriger les investigations.
C'est une personne très froide.
J'ai eu la sensation que c'était
une personne impénétrable.
Il avait cette attitude de...
Comment dire...
Comme s'il cherchait presque à nous
faire croire qu'il était un exalté.
Mais dès le jour suivant nous est apparu
l'éventualité d'une seconde personne,
d'un second tireur.
Les policiers ont en effet
recueilli les premiers témoignages.
Depuis sa fontaine, Lowell Newton,
le photographe américain,
a entendu les trois coups
de feu très rapprochés.
Il a vu un homme en blouson de
cuir tenant une arme à la main droite,
et une sacoche en cuir
dans la main gauche.
Il a pris ces deux photos.
Des photos de l'homme en train de fuir.
Pourtant, Ali Agca maintient sa version.
Il aurait agi sans complice ni commanditaire,
dans le seul but de protester contre le sionisme
et contre la mainmise capitaliste.
Ali Agca est déféré dès le 20 juillet 1981
devant la première cour d'assises de Rome.
250 journalistes
et une trentaine de télévisions,
ont été accrédités
pour suivre les audiences.
Son défenseur, un avocat commis d'office,
plaide le fanatisme religieux.
Le criminel protégé par une vitre
blindée se montre très agité.
Il invective journalistes et magistrats.
Il réfute la légitimité du tribunal,
et menace d'entamer une grève de la faim.
Quoi qu'il en soit,
Ali Agca maintient sa version.
Il a agi seul par conviction politique.
Deux jours d'audiences suffissent à condamner
Mehmet Ali Agca à la prison à vie.
Peine assortie d'un an à l'isolement.
Visiblement, les autorités
ont souhaité classer l'affaire.
Elles ont traité cet attentat comme
l'acte isolé d'un déséquilibré.
Un grand classique.
De Henri IV à John Kennedy,
c'est presque toujours ainsi qu'ont
été présentés les attentats politiques.
Mais la justice italienne
n'en a pas fini avec Ali Agca.
Beaucoup ne croient pas
à sa version du tueur isolé.
Avait-il des complices ?
Qui est cet homme pris en photo
en train de fuir le jour de l'attentat ?
Le geste d'Ali Agca
aurait-il été commandité ?
Et par qui ?
Pour répondre à ces questions,
une nouvelle instruction est ouverte.
Durant les quatre années qui vont suivre,
le juge antiterroriste Ilario Martella,
va tenter de résoudre le mystère
de ce qu'on a appelé la piste bulgare.
C'est cette enquête que le juge Martella
nous raconte maintenant.
La cour d'assise de Rome avait
des suspicions sur le fait qu'Agca,
n'avait pas agi seul.
J'ai donc eu l'occasion de l'interroger
de nombreuses fois,
et à chaque fois que je l'interrogeais,
ses déclarations étaient différentes
de la fois précédentes.
Mais à la fin du mois d'avril 1982,
j'ai reçu une lettre de sa part,
dans laquelle il se déclarait disposé
à collaborer avec la justice.
La version d'Ali Agca
change du tout au tout.
En effet, il met maintenant en cause deux
complices,
Oral Celik qui auraient été présents
sur les lieux de l'attentat,
et surtout Sergueï Antonov,
chef d'escale à Rome pour
la compagnie d'aviation bulgare.
Lui aussi aurait été présent
place Saint-Pierre.
Naturellement,
une telle déclaration faite par Agca,
était à prendre
avec beaucoup de prudence.
Cette piste est explosive,
car elle implique
les services secrets bulgares,
ce qui revient à mettre en cause
les services des pays communistes,
autrement dit, Moscou.
Depuis ses bureaux du palais de justice,
le juge Martella, lance les policiers
sur la piste des complices d'Ali Agca.
C'est moi qui est arrêté Antonov
avec d'autres membres de la DIGOS.
En exécution d'un ordre émis
par le juge Martella.
Il s'est montré très surpris.
Alors qu'Antonov nie toute
implication dans l'attentat,
et affirme ne même pas connaître Ali Agca.
Force est de constater que ce dernier
avance des détails troublants,
notamment sur la vie d'Antonov,
et sur ce à quoi
ressemble son appartement.
De plus, Ali Agca affirme qu'il était censé
fuir à bord d'un camion de déménagement,
devant partir de l'ambassade de Bulgarie.
Vérification faite,
on s'aperçoit qu'un camion de déménagement,
a bel et bien quitté l'ambassade
1h précisément après l'attentat.
Antonov est inculpé.
Le 27 mai 1985,
les journalistes du monde entier envahissent
à nouveau le palais de justice,
pour assister cette fois
au procès de la piste bulgare.
Dans le box des accusés,
Antonov.
Ali Agca est le témoin principal,
tout le monde veut entendre ce que va dire
l'homme qui a tiré sur le pape.
L'ambiance est électrique.
Seulement,
les preuves matérielles sont minces.
On croit reconnaître Antonov sur
une photo prise au moment de l'attentat.
L'accusation repose en vérité
sur les dires d'Ali Agca.
Un Ali Agca qui tout à coup décide
de changer à nouveau sa version des faits.
Il se rétracte en plein procès,
et affirme ne pas connaître Antonov.
Pour fausses.
Je vois cet homme pour
la première fois de ma vie,
Pour la première fois face à face !
Je ne l'ai jamais vu de ma vie !
Stupeur dans la salle, Agca paraît délirer.
Il prétend même être Jésus.
Au, nom de Dieu Tout-Puissant,
j'annonce la fin du monde
Je suis Jesus Christ réincarné.
Le juge est exaspéré, faute de preuve,
la piste bulgare est enterrée.
Antonov est relaxé.
Le verdict est bien sûr insatisfaisant.
Et le premier responsable de ce verdict,
c'est Ali Agca lui-même.
Il a embrouillé
les idées de tout le monde,
et aussi de ceux qui devaient le juger.
A l'évidence,
les éléments matériels recueillis,
étaient tels que le procès a abouti non
pas à une sentence de pleine absolution,
mais à un verdict de relaxe
pour insuffisance de preuve.
Cela signifie, dans la loi italienne,
que les preuves étaient bien là,
mais qu'elles étaient insuffisantes,
pour émettre une condamnation.
Qui a eu l'idée de tuer le pape ?
Qui a financé l'opération ?
Qui a fourni les armes ?
Autant de questions sans réponses
définitives à ce jour.
La thèse la plus inattendue certainement,
a été défendue par l'assassin lui-même.
Oui, Ali Agca,
plus de 30 ans après les faits,
devaient publier un livre,
"Je devais tuer le pape."
Or, dans ce livre, il affirme avoir
agi non pour le compte du KGB,
ou d'une quelconque
officine du bloc de l'Est,
mais à l'instigation directe
de l'Iran des mollahs,
l'Iran de la Révolution islamique.
Aussi étonnant que cela paraisse,
Agca aurait agi sur ordre
de l'ayatollah Khomeini,
ordre de tuer le pape au nom d'Allah.
On prête ou non, foi à ces allégations.
Le moins qu'on puisse dire
est que le mystère demeure.
Et l'on comprend que William Casey,
à l'époque directeur de la CIA,
ait pu dire que l'affaire de la tentative
d'assassinat contre Jean-Paul II,
constituait le plus grand secret
d'État du XXᵉ siècle.
De son côté, le pape, avec l'énergie
stupéfiante qu'on lui connaissait,
s'est spectaculairement remis
de ses blessures, pourtant sévères.
En juin 1991, il se rend en Pologne,
maintenant libéré du joug communiste.
Il y est reçu par le premier président
de la République démocratiquement élu,
un certain Lech Walesa.
Le mur de Berlin est tombé.
L'empire soviétique s'est désintégré.
Les peuples d'Europe de l'Est
se sont libérés de la peur.
Le 27 septembre 1983,
Jean-Paul II était allé rencontrer
Ali Agca dans sa cellule.
Une rencontre inouïe,
filmée par l'entrebâillement
de la porte.
On ne saura jamais ce que
se sont dit les deux hommes.
Le pape devait simplement déclarer,
ce dont nous avons parlé restera
un secret entre lui  et moi.
Je lui ai parlé comme à un frère
à qui j'ai pardonné,
et qui a mon entière confiance.
Selon les confidences
de Stanislaw Dziwisz,
Jean-Paul II aurait dit d'Agca,
"Ni repentir, ni regret.
Il n'a pas prononcé le mot pardon."
Ali Agca n'en a pas moins été deux fois
pardonné par Jean-Paul II.
Il est sorti de prison
le 18 janvier 2010,
après 29 années de détention.
Aujourd'hui il affirme
être devenu catholique,
et aller se recueillir très régulièrement
sur la tombe de sa cible.